Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vouset activez la petite cloche !
Bonjour les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
J'ai reçu une lettre de Monsieur
Vangorfrercs...
Van...
cran... !@$#96!!
Vraiment
certainespersonnes ont
« un nom à coucher dehors ».
Mais quel rapport entre le patronyme
et une nuitpassée,
sous les ponts à la belle étoile ?
Cette expression remonte au Moyen-Âge.
A l'époque,
les campagnes et les rues étaient souvent mal famées.
Les agressions étaient fréquentes.
Aussi
lesaubergistes étaient-ils très méfiants.
Dès que la nuit tombait,
les portes étaient fermées à doubletour.
Quand un client se présentait,
il devait alors décliner son identité
à travers le judas.
Si son nom n'avait pas une consonance locale,
la porte lui restait fermée.
Il passait la nuit à labelle étoile
à cause de son « un nom à coucher dehors ».